It is an understatement
to call the last 24 hours chaoti
for Twitter
or the whole time since Elon Mus
the company.
We are witnessing
what could be an epic meltdown
in real time.
Twitter employees have rejected
Musk's quote, hardcore ultimatum
And there's a mass exodus
going on at the company this mor
In response Twitter closed its o
all of them suspended
employee badge
access,
leaving the company's future
completely thrown into uncertain
And take a look at this.
This is the company
headquarters in San Francisco.
Last night,
someone took it upon themselves
to troll the mogul
with a number of projected messa
such as bankruptcy, baby and, qu
worthless billionaire.
Joining us
now, Sarah Fisher, senior
media analyst and Axios media re
I mean,
like you can sort of laugh at th
of throwing that up on the build
but the reality is
these are
thousands of people's livelihood
3700 have already been let go.
What happens to the rest?
And a medium that is imperfect,
but that many people rely on
for a lot of important news
and outside of the United States
especially with freedom of the p
and freedom of speech isn't a gi
People
all around the world
have been relying on Twitter
for the past decade
plus to be able to call out
autocratic regimes or times.
And they're trying
to fight for democracy.
That could be over.
If Twitter shuts down
and as of this morning,
what you were hearing from sourc
Twitter is that the people respo
for keeping this app alive, deve
that are making sure
you can sign into the app,
you can address problems, they'r
Let's just say, now what?
So then what happens now?
Because I'm sure people are
checking their Twitter
to see if it's even up and runni
And the most concerning part
is if you log out of Twitter,
sometimes it might be hard
to get back in Twitter
because two factor
authentication, the
two people and teams running
that are no longer there, a lot
So what happens next now?
Elon Musk says he's not worried.
He says all the best people
who are there remain.
But sources inside Twitter
tell me we should be worried.
The critical response teams
that manage both the backend cod
and the front, end
quote, have been completely got
Trust and safety
teams, people that are monitorin
misinformation, disinformation,
they are completely gutted,
even design teams
and engineering
teams working on Elon's new proj
like the new verification tools.
Most of them have resigned.
So people can even get back into
because the 22 factor authentica
which I have set up
and everyone should have set
up, is not working.
Yeah, for some people is not wor
And that's one of the biggest is
right now
is if you have a critical proble
for example,
a friend of mine is a journalist
and her account has been hacked.
There's no way to address these
No one there.
There's no one's there's
no there's no safety response
teams is engineers.
There is no communication
since time for journalists
to ask questions.
If you were on Twitter last nigh
I was way too late,
all of these people are tweeting
like basically their goodbyes,
like the Titanic is sinking.
They think that Twitter
is not going to be operable
for much longer.
Is that realistic
or are people
getting ahead of themselves?
Like, what do you what's your.
These are inside
engineers who believe that.
So I think it's absolutely reali
And one of the challenges is
for people who did click
yes on Elon
Musk's form,
saying, okay,
I'm going to
commit to the hardcore Twitter.
They're not committing for long.
What sources told me is that, lo
I just hit. Yes.
Because we're heading into the h
and I still need health insuranc
and I still need to make sure
I can have a job.
There's no even guarantee
about these severance payments.
People aren't getting emails
from any sort of H.R.
department explaining what's goi
I'm confused
because I wonder what you think
he sent that email saying, you k
say yes or no.
If you're committing to hard cor
and that he closed the offices.
Yes.
And also, there was no no,
there was just a yes.
So it's either you resign. Yes.
Or you don't do it. And the reas
And the reason that he by the wa
the offices we are hearing
is because there's
a little sense of paranoia right
He doesn't want the Twitter empl
who are remaining to rebel again
But how what would they do then?
You mean just sabotage
and shut the site down,
set the site down and mess
with the code, mess with the off
But that is probably the worst s
that you can be in
if you're Elon Musk right now
of the 2900 employees
that were left going into this 5
deadline yesterday.
We've heard that hundreds have d
that they're leaving the company
Many have tweeted
publicly that they're leaving th
with the Emoji Salute sign,
which is sort of been
the sign for I'm leaving Twitter
after many years.
And so this looks like chaos fro
I, I just keep thinking
about the fact, guys, that this
you know, when you're a public c
you have more checks, right?
And you have a board of advisors
and the board
can oust an ineffective leader
and that's all gone all that's g
The board has been gutted.
There's no accountability.
And the people inside Twitter
are Elon's close confidant.
Friends are running it with his
and some of them I know
and their sources, and they're g
and they're smart people.
There were
a lot of former
Twitter people in the beginning
who came in to do some of this w
And I think the curious thing
is going to be
who sticks with Elon
as they watch this ship
move into this direction?
Do you want to have your reputat
being staked on
what really looks like a mass
destruction of this app?
Can I ask you,
is this
money or too much money or too m
Yes.
Men, people up men,
because it's not a lot of women
are all the above. That's what I
All of the above like.
Is it just you know what I'm say
I think it's all those things
and I think it's a lot of ego
I think there has been this ment
in Silicon Valley
that if you push fast,
you know, move fast and break th
that you're going to be more eff
But there is a tipping point.
And I think that we have crossed
line at Twitter.
I think Icarus by Too Close to t
And remember what
the Airbnb CEO told us yesterday
It's like a nightclub
and all the lights just came on.
I can't even remember yesterday,
but I do remember that tonight.
Thank you, Sarah.
Good to see you. Great, great st